hello my name is Francesco PSAC I'm from
Mexico my program it's called italia tu
casa which means put your heart into
your home i'm going to answer what keep
me motivated to the motivation is to
provide any whole world the opportunity
to have us on an affordable home for all
the families that doesn't have in the
world which is a million people a
billion people 1000 million people in
the world does not have a phone call
what's the most interesting idea that i
have heard today about the World
Economic Forum well they idea is that
the world coming term is not what the
most of the people thinks that it's the
richest club in the world it is not is
the richest opportunity for everybody in
the world that's what the world climate
for me it's to provide an equal
opportunity to everybody I think that
the gnosis to explain thing I have
learned today